[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo tout de suite les
titres de ce vendredi 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes
le cidff centre d'information sur les
droits des femmes et des familles des
yvelines a lancé ce vendredi matin sa
première permanence dans le sud yvelines
à rambouillet aurore bergé était
présente pour l'inauguration
l'association créatrice ces femmes
entrepreneurs aux rup 150 femmes des
yvelines elles se retrouvent pour
promouvoir leurs activités et acquérir
de nouvelles compétences par les changes
et l'entr'aide zoom à suivre sur l'une
de leurs rencontres à poissy en cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes martha de sidrac sénatrice des
yvelines et membre du bureau de la
délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les femmes
et les hommes commentera le reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
le centre d'information sur les droits
des femmes et des familles des yvelines
plus simplement appelée le cidff a
inauguré ce vendredi matin une
permanence juridique à rambouillet plus
précisément au sein de l' usine à
chapeaux
cette association départementale
intervient dans les domaines de l'accès
au droit
l'aide aux victimes ou encore l'égalité
femmes hommes
il existe 50 ans un lieu de permanence
dans les yvelines mais celle de
rambouillet avait fermé il ya quelques
années faute de financement la députée
de la 10e circonscription aurore bergé a
sollicité la secrétaire d'état marlène
schiappa afin d'obtenir une subvention
exceptionnelle de 14000 euros par an
pour cette nouvelle permanence du
sud-yvelines écouter que vous soyez à
versailles saint-germain-en-laye à
mantes la jolie à rambouillet ou dans
les plus petits villages qu'on peut
avoir dans le sud du département
vous êtes concernés de la même manière
dans les territoires ruraux on a aussi
évidemment des questions
d'accompagnement des deux victimes
question des violences qu'on parle aussi
d'inégalités salariales sa touche toutes
les femmes et toutes les catégories
sociales dont 5200 victimes en 2018 reçu
dont 1700 femmes victimes de violences
conjugales ont reçu au sein du cidff
dédié ligne ça représente une grosse
part de notre activité quand on est tous
formés au cidff d'accompagnement des
femmes victimes de violence
spécifiquement avec nous en plateau pour
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes martha de sidrac bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la sénatrice des
yvelines
aurore bergé ont la vue était présente
ce vendredi matin pour l'inauguration du
cidff le centre d'information sur les
droits des femmes et des familles des
yvelines vous aussi vous vous engagez
pour la promotion des femmes en
politique et une étude de l'insee
publiée jeudi révèle qu'en ile de france
un maire sur cinq est une femme et c'est
dans le département des yvelines que la
présence de femmes r est la plus faible
avec et 18,4 pour cent
les femmes sont écartés des hautes
responsabilités martha de sidrac alors
écarté n'ont peut-être pas moi je dirais
cela différemment parce que je me suis
engagé en politique aussi parce que
j'étais une famille parce que je pense
que nous les femmes nous ont pas parfois
aller jusqu'au bout de l'exercice
on a toujours cette envie de nous rendre
utile de se sentir utile
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous voyez
beaucoup de femmes qui s'engagent dans
le monde associatif qui a une réputation
d'être un petit peu plus peut-être soft
que excusez moi de cet anglicisme que ne
l'est le monde politique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle parfois les femmes
n'osent pas aller jusqu'au bout de leurs
ambitions parce qu'ils ont non parce
qu'ils ont les compétences et parce
qu'ils ont aussi aujourd'hui il faut le
savoir mesdames je m'adresse à l avant
tout cette possibilité-là leur est
offerte donc moi je dis toujours il ne
s'agit pas de pousser les hommes
dehors c'est absolument pas du tout
comme ça que je m'inscris dans cette
démarche et dans cet engagement mais je
dis tout simplement nous les femmes nous
sommes là ne nous oubliez pas et il ne
s'agit pas aussi d'attendre que l'on
vient nous chercher mais il faut que
nous en serons gnac faut vraiment y
aller alors justement vous êtes
également membre du réseau élu local et
vous participer à l'événement du
vendredi 29 mars qu'elle est programme
de cette journée c'est un c'est une
journée un peu particulière puisque
habituellement les journées nationales
famille lui donc du réseau que vous
venez de citer a lieu en novembre donc
plutôt à la rentrée en général après des
grandes vacances
là cette fois ci c'est une rencontre en
fait avec l'ensemble des références des
réseaux des réseaux nationale donc moi
je serai bien évidemment présentes au
titre des yvelines et beaucoup de mes
collègues puisque nous sommes tout élu
dans nos territoires allons
effectivement abordé ces sujets que vous
venez d'évoquer y compris à travers les
statistiques dans nos territoires
respectifs pour essayer de trouver
pourquoi pas des actions communes à
mener est en tout cas des encouragements
pour toutes celles qui souhaiteraient
s'engager un peu plus loin en politique
une particularité en amont de cette
journée la veille
alors oui la veille merci de me tendre
cette perche puisque le réseau en fait
yvelinois va avoir cette spécificité ça
sera le seul dans le cadre du réseau élu
local au national de se transformer en
association donc l'association sera
lancée le 28 mars donc la veille de
cette grande journée élu local et à
cette occasion là nous aurons l'occasion
de faire un évènement et vous bien sûr
les médias locaux sera invité de manière
à pouvoir nous accompagner et nous
donner cet écho que parfois les femmes
en politique non pas reviendra et en
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes nous nous sommes intéressés à
l'association femmes entrepreneures ce
réseau professionnel de l'ouest parisien
rassemble 150 femmes elles se retrouvent
une fois par semaine l'une des
adhérentes michel richer créatrice de
bijoux nous a ouvert les portes de son
atelier à poissy des femmes
entrepreneurs ou porteuses de projets
elles sont en traiteur à domicile coach
comptable ou encore sophrologue le ch
accompagne les femmes et les hommes mais
les femmes dans la gestion du stress
les problèmes de sommeil de burnout
elles se retrouvent pour un business
buzz organisé par l'association femmes
entrepreneurs qui regroupe 150 membres
en moyenne ce sont des événements de
réseautage de networking comme on dit en
anglais
l'idée c'est de rassembler les personnes
de les mettre en relation de les faire
se rencontrer
et puis dans en espérer avec le long
terme des synergies des opportunités
michel richer ancien architecte a convié
les adhérentes de l'association femmes
entrepreneures chez elle à poissy elle a
fait les beaux-arts puis a travaillé
pour un fabricant de luminaires pendant
22 ans
passionné par le verre de murano elle a
décidé de lancer sa marque de bijoux
milo gina et moi j'avais envie en fait
de travailler le verre de murano mais
avec l'élégance française avec des
choses plus épuré plus sobre bagues
boucles d'oreilles broches ou encore
collier des créations qu'elle porte sur
elle
je pense que j'ai évolué avec l'âge il
ya vingt ans je me serais pas senti
entrepreneur je sentais pas l'âme d'un
autre d'entrepreneurs j'étais bien en
tant que salarié quelque part j'ai
découvert la sécurité les enfants
grandissant les enfants est en partie du
nih et ailleurs acquis de l'expérience
on peut en fait prétendre à sac c'est
une deuxième vie qui commence beaucoup
de ces femmes ont eu une activité de
salarié pour certaines c'est une
reconversion suite un changement de vie
un divorce ou encore un retour
d'expatriation
ça fait maintenant quatre ans je fais
partie
et ça a été une très grande aide pour
moi lors de cette rencontre chacune
pitch son business en une minute
l'occasion de partager leurs expériences
je me suis inscrite pour pouvoir
rencontrer du monde au niveau local
et puis au niveau des femmes il ya une
grosse dynamique et une émulation et
entraide entre entre les femmes
l'association a édité un livre des
créatrices et femmes entrepreneurs à
l'ouest de paris afin de promouvoir ses
membres au delà des événements organisés
toute l'année
journée du 8 mars l'occasion de faire un
bilan en france une femme gagne en
moyenne 26% de moins qu'un homme
quelles sont vos missions au sénat pour
lutter contre ce phénomène alors à la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat à laquelle j'appartiens je suis
membre du bureau
il est vrai que c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous sommes très très regardante
en fait on essaie de le suivre de près
donc
il ya différents sujets l'année dernière
ça a été nous avions à un fort axe
autour de tout ce qui était violences
faites aux femmes
et donc nous avons porté un certain
nombre de propositions autour de cela
moi même avec ma collègue maryvonne
blondin vont à blonde un pardon avons
édité un rapport au tour de ceux de ce
phénomène qui existe toujours
aujourd'hui
et cette année là nous sommes axés
également nous on ne perd donc pas de
vue malheureusement toute cette
actualité qui nous rattrape
on connaît les chiffres y compris pour
2019 qui commencent à tomber
mais nous continuons plus loin nous
essayons d'aller un peu plus loin dans
nos travaux et puisque toute violence
faite aux femmes ça comprend bien
évidemment la violence physique ça
comprend la violence morale mais ça
comprend aussi toutes les inégalités que
parfois les femmes subissent aujourd'hui
dans notre société et nous avons eu la
loi copé zimmermann pour les conseils
d'administration je crois que il est
important aussi qu'on s'attelle à un
moment donné aux vrais lieux peut-être
de pouvoir au sein des entreprises que
sont les commerçants les comités
exécutifs puisqu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas de règle autour de cela or
c'est un sujet qui nous à la délégation
aux droits des femmes nous intéresse
donc pour l'instant nous y réfléchissons
où nous auditionnons beaucoup donc nous
continuons sur différents fronts à la
fois les tout ce qui est violence comme
je voulais dit mais aussi tout ce qui
pourrait à un moment donné émerger pour
nous permettre d'aller vers des voies
plus législatif et qui ne sont pas de
mon point de vue l'idéal mais s'il faut
passer par une fois de plus le
le législatif peut-être faut-il y aller
alors les lois s'enchaînent depuis 1972
mais les salaires de femmes sont
toujours inférieurs pour réduire les
inégalités salariales
le gouvernement a mis en place depuis le
1er mars un nouvel index pour
sanctionner les entreprises ne
respectant pas la loi
il s'agit d'un outil de calcul des
salaires pour se rendre compte des
injustices au sein d'une entreprise et
pour les corriger
seuls 6% des entreprises françaises
versent des salaires égaux à leurs
employés quelles sanctions sont prévues
pour ces entreprises
alors en terme de sanction aujourd'hui
pour les entreprises
il est prévu en fait des pénalités en
tant que tel simplement il y a comme
dans beaucoup de domaines des
entreprises qui préfèrent payer régler
ces pénalités là et ne pas forcément
rentrer dans ce dans les dispositifs que
la loi aujourd'hui oblige dans 2
de mettre en place dans nos instances
mais je pense que il y a un vrai sujet
c'est ne pas passer par la sanction
vis-à-vis des entreprises mais pas c'est
plutôt par aussi cette prise de
conscience réelle qui commence à faire
du chemin et que commencent à venir au
niveau du sénat nous y travaillons deux
m'ont démontré et de montrer et de j'ai
envie de dire de marteler le fait que
toute entreprise dans laquelle nous
avons autant d'hommes que de femmes
mais pas que autant d'hommes que de
femmes il peut y avoir quand même dans
certaines entreprises plus d'hommes plus
de femmes est en tout cas que dès lors
que vous avez une vraie mixité
vous avez en fait une performance qui
est tant dévoué qui est supérieure à
celle que l'on connaît jusque là donc je
pense que c'est plus en positivant cette
action là qu'on arrivera à nos fins
plutôt qu en pénalisant systématiquement
les entreprises qu'ils n'y arriveraient
pas puisque il y a malgré tout ce qui
est quelque chose de très lourd dans
notre société
beaucoup d'à priori aujourd'hui qui
colle à la peau autour d'eux des femmes
dans l'entreprise autour des compétences
des femmes
alors justement au sein des entreprises
prévient près d'un tiers des femmes
travaillent en temps partiel pour
s'occuper souvent des enfants depuis
2002 les jeunes papas ont le droit en
congé paternité de 11 jours trop court
pour certains qui jugent sa durée
insuffisante
plusieurs pétitions et propositions vont
dans ce sens dans ce sens allongé et
rendre obligatoire le congé paternité
permettrait-il selon vous une meilleure
égalité professionnelle entre les femmes
et les hommes moi je pense que de toute
façon le congé doit être égale pour les
deux c'est un choix libre dans la
famille que ce soit le papa que ce soit
la maman qui décide de prendre quelques
jours de congé voire les deux il faut
que nous ayons cette liberté là dans nos
dans notre dans notre pays mais il faut
aussi quand même ramener cela au à
l'égalité salariale puisque vous le
savez bien moi même dans ma propre
famille à un moment donné lorsque
monsieur et madame travail
et lorsqu'il y a des choix à faire au
tour des enfants quand ils sont petits
puisqu'il ya tout le sujet des gardes
enfants aussi qui se greffent là dessus
le calcul et économiques dans la fugue
est avant tout est de nos jours ça l'est
encore plus c'est très prégnant et donc
le calcul est très simple on regarde qui
gagnent plus et c'est celui là qui va
garder son travail à temps plein et
celui qui gagne moins prendre un temps
partiel aujourd'hui les femmes en font
clairement les frais donc je pense qu'il
ya un vrai travail
il ne faut pas le traiter ce sujet là en
silo 1 il faut véritablement voir
l'ensemble de ce que notre société
aujourd'hui à comme mode de
fonctionnement il faut il faut partir du
terrain et laisser la liberté aux
familles aux couples de s'organiser
comme ils le souhaitent mais il faut que
ce choix là permettent à l'homme ou à la
femme à un moment donné dans leur vie
l'un sera à mi temps le temps partiel
temps complet qu'importe que ce soit le
papa ou la maman alors pour dénoncer les
inégalités salariales entre les sexes
des associations appellent à la grève en
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes
baptisé et 8 mars 15h40 l'heure des
comptes
la grève a débuté à 15h40 heure à partir
de laquelle les femmes travaillaient
gratuitement
cet écart s'explique notamment par les
nombreux emplois à temps partiel occupés
par les femmes dans les yvelines des
grévistes sont recensées sur le site
nexter à versailles le mouvement sera
prolongée samedi 9 mars avec le renfort
des femmes gilet jaune qui se mettront
en première ligne dans les
manifestations nous passons à présent à
notre rubrique ça s'est passé comme
chaque vendredi
retour sur l'actualité à travers nos
archives et en cette journée du 8 mars
journée internationale des droits des
femmes
retour en mars 2006 nous nous étions
rendus au centre de formation des
apprentis en bâtiment et travaux publics
attrape seulement 6
femmes étaient inscrits pour apprendre
ce que l'on qualifie de métier d'homme
[Musique]
l'an dernier aucune fille ne suivait une
formation dans ce centre cette année
elles sont sept
la majorité d'entre elles après par un c
ap peinture comme justin et anaïs leur
point commun une assurance à toute
épreuve
c'est vrai que c'est un défi quand même
parce que mon écart seront pas très
facile il faut faire ses preuves comme
je vous ai dit il faut montrer qu'on a
du caractère faut pas se laisser marcher
sur les pieds
faire évoluer les mentalités n'est pas
évident comme partout ce cfa pratique
l'alternance et lorsqu'elles ont dû
partir à la recherche d'une entreprise
les portes sont souvent restées closes
j'ai eu beaucoup de noms intérêt pour ce
négatif j y en a eu beaucoup
et quelques-unes parfois oui mais trop
loin chez moi donc souvent de dix noms
et recherchent pas d'apprentis ou non
ils ont déjà quelqu'un on ce banal je le
prenais dans le bon sens quoi je me
disais qu'il faut que je continue
puis j'ai continué enfin on m'a aidé
aussi élevé dans un milieu fortement
masculin toutes ces jeunes femmes n'ont
en tout cas pas baisser les bras pour
parvenir à leur but
le cas de leurs marchands inscrits en
travaux publics est encore plus
significatif
elle est également engagée pour l'armée
en tant que réserviste
je trouve tout le temps quelque chose à
faire niveau de l'armée c'est aussi un
un projet peut-être par l'avenir et à
allier les deux donc travailler dans
l'armée mais dans le btp d'accord il est
mieux trop que ça non parce qu'il faut
rien ni suspendus à des listes que les
éléments ce sont des pistes quand on
sait travailler on peut trouver le but
c'est moi pour moi c'est je le trouvais
dans n'importe quelle entreprise tant
qu'on sait travailler on aura toujours
quelque chose par derrière
on aura toujours le boulot donc que ce
soit un homme ou une femme c'est
toujours la même chose qui est cet
engouement féminin pour les métiers
traditionnellement réservé aux hommes
pourraient permettre de mettre fin à la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans le btp
chaque année il manque encore entre 700
et 1000 apprentis dans les yvelines
[Musique]
on passe à présent reste de l'actualité
de la semaine
[Musique]
dans le monde une femme sur trois subit
des violences physiques et ou sexuelle
d'un partenaire à un moment de sa vie
cette semaine les derniers chiffres de
la délinquance en ile-de-france ont été
révélés par le ministère de l'intérieur
bilan très mauvais pour les agressions
sexuelles qui ont augmenté de 25% en un
an sur paris et dans les hauts de seine
dans les yvelines ce sont surtout les
vols par fausse qualité qui sont en
hausse avec les personnes âgées comme
principale cible
une femme meurt tous les trois jours en
france de violences faites par son
compagnon ou ex-compagnon vous porter le
ruban blanc signe de lutte contre ces
violences faites aux femmes
et depuis le mois de janvier trente
femmes sont décédées sous les coups de
leur compagnon ou ex-compagnon 30
j'ai trop beaucoup trop et c'est
toujours trop il y en aurait qu'une ça
serait déjà trop de toute façon dont je
pense qu'il faut que nous soyons
collectivement conscient de ce que
certaines d'entre nous subissons quand
je dis certains d'entre nous j'inclus
les hommes aussi parce que toute
violence faite à une femme est une
violence faite à l'ensemble de l'être
humain des enfants qui peuvent en être
impactés des conjoints des compagnons
des frères des soeurs puisque les
violences faites aux femmes ne sont pas
parfois celles que l'on s'imagine
spontanément c'est un sujet lourd
les chiffres que l'on voit ne sont
inquiétants et je crois aujourd'hui et
c'est le combat que nous menons
également au niveau de la délégation au
sénat délégation aux droits des femmes
les budgets sont insuffisants je le dis
très clairement je l'ait déjà alger
d'hégelé déjà de lier à madame marlène
schiappa parce que on voit l'exemple de
l'espagne en espagne les moyens ont été
mis en voix qu'il y a eu tout de suite
une baisse significative des violences
faites aux femmes
donc je crois qu'on ne peut pas se
contenter uniquement de prévention je
crois qu'il ne faut de vraies actions
dans nos territoires est une vraie
sensibilisation qu'ils soient
accompagnées de moyens
or ce sont les moyens qui nous manque
beaucoup dans nos territoires
je travaille j'ai chant souvent avec
marie à cerner ce qui est en fait notre
déléguée aux
ray de la préfecture sur ces thématiques
et on voit que parfois nous demandons
nous les élus locaux d' sur les
territoires des moyens qui n'arrivent
pas par l'état donc je le dis très
clairement il nous faut plus de moyens
sur ce fléau parce que c'est un fléau
est un pays comme le nôtre ne peut pas
accepter ne peut pas tolérer qu'il y ait
une femme aujourd'hui qui meurt sous les
coups d'un compagnon d'un conjoint d'un
homme d'un homme tous les trois jours et
ne rien laisser passer c'est le message
qu'on veut lui transmettre les membres
du gouvernement un portail de
signalement des violences sexuelles a
été lancée au commissariat de guyancourt
fin novembre elle est victime de
violences sexuelles et sexistes peuvent
désormais dialoguer être accompagnés à
distance par des policiers spécialisés
accessibles en quelques clics
en se rendant sur services tirés
public.fr depuis huit ans la ville de
guyancourt consacre le mois de mars aux
femmes le temps des femmes a commencé le
30 janvier et s'étend jusqu'au 24 mars
plusieurs animations une exposition pour
afficher la lutte contre les inégalités
femmes hommes
le reportage de marie l'ania puis film
aucune femme dans les 15 personnalités
préférées des français
les objets ne sont pas des femmes l'un
verts sont plus des chiffres des slogans
des visuels chocs dans le cadre de son
temps des femmes
la ville de guyancourt se pose la
question l'égalité où en est on l'idée
étant de réunir des artistes autour
cette thématique là de l'égalité avec
l'envié en tout cas de montrer les
divers supports du dic du discours
féministe aujourd'hui que ce soit du
street art comme avec les hommes de
mystique qui sont juste derrière moi on
va voir aussi de la vidéo de la fiche de
l'illustration aussi du dessin de presse
notre site toutes les formes que prend
peut prendre le discours autour
l'égalité aujourd'hui une dizaine
d'artistes ont répondu à l'appel parmi
eux arnaud corbin il interpelle le
public avec des chiffres chocs sur des
visuels
je milite et je m'engage pour que
le monde qui nous entoure et put les
gens avec qui on travaille plus que soi
même on essaye d'être respectueux et
vivent dans un monde un tout petit peu
plus tranquille tout petit peu plus
harmonieux un tout petit peu plus
respectueux l'exposition soyons affiché
est au centre de ce mois consacré aux
femmes et entraîner avec elle de
nombreuses animations pour toucher un
public le plus large possible
on a aussi des débats on a aussi au
théâtre notre ferme de bel ébat notre
centre culturel il ya aussi des
représentations théâtrales et on a aussi
une forte chaque année une forte
sensibilisation envers les enfants et
les plus jeunes et il ya plus de 300
jeunes qui se sont inscrits revenir avec
laurent enseignants visiter l'exposition
et puis aussi travailler et c'est ça qui
est le plus important
travailler sur le sujet de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 16 femmes
sont décédées sous les coups de leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint en france
et sachez qu'en france seulement 2% des
rues portent un nom de femme
la ville de trappes a proposé aux
habitants de choisir le nom d'une femme
pour le nouvel équipement d'activités
sportives près de la rue maurice thorez
le nom d'une femme sportive sera donnée
à ce nouvel équipement
'l'annonce des cinq noms retenus
s'effectuera dans les prochains jours
avec la possibilité de voter en ligne
pour le nom final le sport féminin autre
sujet est peu visible la part consacrée
à la retransmission du sport féminin à
la télévision se situe entre 16 et 20 %
que comptez vous faire pour faire
évoluer la place de la femme dans le
milieu sportif
une proposition de loi au sénat
absolument mais côté ça ne peut pas être
plus dans les actualités puisque
actuellement j'ai une collègue céline à
bout les laisse péronier qui est
sénatrice avec d'autres collègues nous
travaillons dès la délégation aux droits
des femmes sur un rapport justement qui
sera prochainement éditée sur tous ces
sujets autour du sport au féminin que
nous devons porter puisque 16 1% là
encore on voit bien qu'il y a une vraie
injustice une véritable inégalité
quand on connaît l'engouement
aujourd'hui que le sport connaît y
compris le sport féminin et nous sommes
dans un territoire dans les yvelines
nous avons des sportives où nous avons
beaucoup de clubs féminins et c'est de
notre j'ai envie de dire devoir
collectif de le promouvoir ce sport là
mais aussi en visibilité puisque
derrière se joue aussi des enjeux
économiques et tant que les enjeux
économiques ne se seront pas aussi
intéressés et en pareille du sport
féminin
nous allons sans doute être toujours
dans ces écarts là donc il faut
véritablement que tous nous nous y
intéressions de manière à ce que le
le sport féminin tienne sa bonne place
là où il doit être au même niveau que le
sport au masculin
et pour rappel la france accueille la 8e
édition de la coupe féminine du de
football pardon qui se déroulera entre
le 7 juin et le 7 juillet 2019
c'est vraiment important donc de
rappeler ces inégalités entre les femmes
et les hommes
en cette journée internationale des
droits des femmes
on le rappelle également votre événement
le 28 mars le 28 mars nous lançons elie
élu local des yvelines qui a pour
vocation donc de faire adhérer des élues
locales femmes mais également tous les
hommes sont les bienvenus elle leur
l'objet bien évidemment c'est de pouvoir
donner justement cette visibilité à
toutes les actions féminine qu'elles
soient portées par des élus par le monde
associatif par la société civile par
tout un chacun car je crois qu'en fait
on s'enrichirait tous mutuellement de
pouvoir travailler beaucoup plus
ensemble et de moins nous diviser avant
tout nous sommes des êtres humains et je
crois que cet universalisme doit nous
réunir et nous permettre d'avancer
ensemble et on clôturera cette f2 sur
ces belles phrases merci marquage de
l'irak
tu te rappelles vous êtes la sénatrice
des yvelines c'est la fin de ce cette
fuite l'hebdo en cette journée
internationale des droits des femmes
retour de l'information lundi dans le
7-8 journal passer un excellent week-end
[Musique]